>> Tucker: LOOKING AT LIVE
PICTURES FROM CAPITOL HILL.
SETTING UP THE RULES FOR
IMPEACHMENT VOTE THEY ARE
APPARENTLY GOING TO HOLD
TOMORROW.
THE HOUSE IS TEMPORARILY IN
RECESS RECONVENING IN ABOUT
A HALF AN HOUR.
WE ARE MONITORING THE
SITUATION THERE GOOD
EVENING, WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT" IT.
IS HERE AFTER MONTHS OF
FALSE STARTS AND THREATS AND
ENDLESS POS TEMPERATURING
BY.
SO SADDEST, MOST INEFFECTIVE
PEOPLE IN AMERICA,
IMPEACHMENT APPARENTLY IS
IMMINENT BARRING SOME
LAST-MINUTE PLOTS TWISTS AND
THAT COULD HAPPEN LESS THAN
24 HOURS FROM NOW.
DONALD TRUMP WILL JOIN
ANDREW JOHNSON AND BILL
CLINTON AS THE THIRD
AMERICAN PRESIDENT EVER
IMPEACHED BY THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
WE'RE THINKING AT THIS POINT
THE FINAL VOTE TOMORROW
AFTERNOON DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN PROMISING TO DO THIS
BEFORE THE PRESIDENT WAS
EVER ELECTED PRESIDENT AND
YET, STILL, FEELS KIND OF
WEIRD.
SURPRISING, SURREAL, EVEN,
THAT IT'S FINALLY GOING TO
HAPPEN WHY?
BECAUSE IMPEACHMENT AND
THERE IS REALLY NO
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT, THIS IS
A TERRIBLE IDEA FOR THE
COUNTRY.
AT THIS POINT THERE IS NO
QUESTION THE DEMOCRATS CAN'T
ACTUALLY REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT.
AND IN TRYING, THEY WILL
ONLY HURT THEMSELVES.
THE POLLS ARE CLEAR.
YET, AND HERE IS THE
FASCINATING POINT.
THEY ARE DOING IT ANYWAY.
WATCH MARYLAND CONGRESSMAN
JAMIE RASKIN EXPLAIN WHY
THEY ARE DOING IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S
CONTINUING COURSE OF CONDUCT
CONSTITUTES A CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER TO DEMOCRACY
IN AMERICA.
WE CANNOT ALLOW THIS
MISCONDUCT TO PASS.
IT WOULD BE A SELL-OUT OF
OUR CONSTITUTION, OUR
FOREIGN POLICY, OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY AND OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Tucker: SEE IF YOU CAN
FOLLOW THE LOGIC CHAIN.
MAYBE CAN YOU SPOT THE
MISSING LINK.
HERE'S WHAT HE IS ARGUING.
LEAVING A PRESIDENT IN
OFFICE UNTIL VOTERS CAN
DECIDE TO REMOVE HIM FROM
OFFICE IF THEY WANT IS,
QUOTE, A DANGER TO
DEMOCRACY.
IT'S A, QUOTE, SELL OUT OF
OUR CONSTITUTION.
OKAY.
SO, IN CASE YOU HAVE
FORGOTTEN, WHAT IS THE CRIME
THAT UNDERGIRDERS THIS
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDING?
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT
ACCUSED OF DOING?
IN CASE YOU HAVE FORGOTTEN,
IT'S DONALD TRUMP MAY HAVE
DELAYED MILITARY AID TO THE
GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE.
NOW, KEEP IN MIND THE ONLY
PURPOSE OF AID TO THE
GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE IS TO
ANTAGONIZE RUSSIA.
KEEP IN MIND, ALSO, RUSSIA
IS A COUNTRY WITH MORE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS THAN ANY
OTHER COUNTRY ON THE GLOBE.
BUT, ACCORDING TO JAMIE
RASKIN, NOT GIVING WEAPONS
TO UKRAINE IS A CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER TO AMERICA.
IT'S A SELL-OUT HE SAYS OF
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY TO
PAUSE IN A RELENTLESS
ATTACKS ON RUSSIA EVEN FOR A
MOMENT.
THAT'S A REMARKABLE
ASSERTION.
HARD TO BELIEVE HE COULD
DEFEND THAT IN A RATIONAL
CONVERSATION.
BUT IT DOESN'T EVEN STAND
OUT UNDER THE CURRENT
STANDARDS OF POLITICAL
RHETORIC.
THERE IS A LOT OF TALK LIKE
THAT ALL OF THE SUDDEN.
THE ENTIRE IMPEACHMENT SAGA,
IN FACT, HAS BECOME DETACHED
FROM REALITY.
HERE IS THE MOST BASIC FACTS
ABOUT IT.
DEMOCRATS DO NOT HAVE THE
VOTES TO REMOVE PRESIDENT
TRUMP FROM OFFICE.
THEY NEVER WILL HAVE THE
VOTES TO REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT.
THE POINT OF IMPEACHMENT IS
TO REMOVE A PRESIDENT.
THEY CANNOT DO THAT.
THIS PROCESS IS DOOMED
BEFORE IT EVEN BEGINS.
BY THE WAY, THEY DON'T HAVE
THE VOTES BECAUSE VOTERS
DON'T SUPPORT IT.
THE IRONY IS THAT OUR
DEMOCRACY IS WORKING JUST
FINE.
VOTERS SUPPORT IT IN FACT
LESS THAN THEY DID.
AFTER A FULL MONTH OF
WATCHING PUBLIC HEARINGS ON
IMPEACHMENT, DEMOCRATS HAVE
NOT GAINED SUPPORT.
THEY HAVE LOST IT.
IN LATE OCTOBER, WHEN THIS
BEGAN ABOUT HALF THE COUNTRY
BACKED IMPEACHMENT.
44 PERCENT SAID THEY WERE
OPPOSED TO IMPEACHMENT.
IN THE MOST RECENT POLLING,
THOSE NUMBERS HAVE INVERTED,
IN OTHER WORDS, THE MORE
PEOPLE LEARNED ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT THE LESS THEY
WANTED IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S NOT ONE PERSON'S
OPINION.
THAT IS THE SUM TOTAL OF THE
POLLING.
THE NUMBERS COULD NOT BE
CLEARER ON THIS QUESTION.
AND, YET, EVEN IN THE FAILS
OF ALL THOSE DATA, ELITE
DEMOCRATS STILL WILL NOT
ADMIT IT.
THEY ARE LITERALLY IN
DENIAL.
WATCH DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CHEERLEADER JEFFREY TUBEN
ATTACK HIS OWN COMPANY'S
POLLING WHEN IT DOESN'T
MATCH WHAT HE BELIEVES MUST
BE TRUE.
>> YOU SEE A DECLINE FROM
OUR LAST POLL IN DEMOCRATIC
SUPPORT FROM 90% DOWN TO
77%.
>> CAN I JUST SAY MY TWIN
BROTHER, THAT I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT POLL FOR ONE
SECOND.
>> WHAT PART?
>> THE 90% TO 77%.
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST I DON'T
BELIEVE IT.
LIKE IT MAKES NO SENSE THAT
THAT IF NUMBER WOULD CHANGE
LIKE THAT.
>> I MEAN, LIFE MEANS --
LIFE IS -- SOMETIMES POLLS
ARE SOMETIMES WRONG.
>> DAVID, THAT POLL IS
WRONG.
JUST BECAUSE I SAID SO,
OKAY?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: WHY DON'T YOU
BELIEVE IT?
BECAUSE I DON'T.
BECAUSE I LOOK OUT MY WINDOW
AND I SEE THE HORIZON.
THAT MEANS IT'S FLAT.
YOU CAN TELL ME THE EARTH IS
ROUND.
BUT I JUST DON'T BELIEVE IT
ENOUGH ABOUT YOUR DUMB
NUMBERS AND SCIENTIFIC
THEORIES.
I JUST DON'T BELIEVE IT.
SAYS THE LEGAL ANALYST.
OKAY.
WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING
OBVIOUSLY IS ONE MAN DEGRADE
HIMSELF.
IT'S BIGGER THAN THAT IT'S
THE DEFINITION OF
IDEOLOGICAL EXTREMISM.
AND THAT'S THE INABILITY TO
CHANGE COURSE NO MATTER WHAT
THE EVIDENCE TELLS YOU.
SO THAT'S THE POINT AT WHICH
THIS IS NO LONGER POLITICS,
OF COURSE.
WE LEFT THAT A LONG TIME
AGO.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT IS
RELIGION.
AND, OF COURSE, BEING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEIR
RELIGION, IT'S ALWAYS THE
EXACT OPPOSITE OF WHAT THEY
CLAIM IT IS.
SO AS PRESIDENT TRUMP NOTED
IN THE RECENT LETTER TO
NANCY PELOSI AND WE ARE
QUOTING:  YOU ARE THE ONES
INTERFERING IN AMERICA'S
ELECTIONS.
YOU ARE THE ONES SUBVERTING
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
YOU ARE THE ONES BRINGING
PAIN AND SUFFERING TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR YOUR OWN
PERSONAL POLITICAL AND
PARTISAN GAIN.
THE PUBLIC, WHETHER THEY
LIKE TRUMP OR NOT, AGREES
WITH THAT.
THE POLLING SHOWS IT.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS CAN'T
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY ARE
STUCK.
SO IN 2016 THEY WENT ALL IN
ON DENOUNCING TRUMP REMEMBER
THIS BEFORE THE ELECTION AND
EVERY ONE OF HIS SUPPORTERS
YOU, BEYOND THE PALE RACIST
NOT WORTHY OF BEING HATED.
PHYSICALLY ASSAULTED IN SOME
CASES.
THEY LOST ANYWAY.
WHEN THEY DID LOSE, THEY
REFUSED TO LEARN.
THEY REFUSED TO EVEN THINK
FOR A MOMENT ABOUT WHY THEY
MAY HAVE LOST.
AND, INSTEAD, MOVE
SEEMLESSLY FROM RACISM INTO
A CONSPIRACY ABOUT RUSSIA.
SO BIZARRE THEY COULD NEVER
EVEN FULLY EXPLAIN ITS
OUTLINES.
WHAT ARE YOU SAYING YOU
WOULD ASK, RUSSIA THEY WOULD
SAY.
OKAY.
THAT COLLAPSED, YOU WATCHED
IT HAPPEN ON LIVE
TELEVISION.
BUT WHAT HASN'T CHANGED IS
THE RAGE STORM THEY CREATED
WITH YEARS OF PROPAGANDA.
THEY WHIPPED THEIR VOTERS
INTO SUCH A FRENZY THAT THE
VOTERS CAN'T BE PULLED BACK
NOW.
THEY WANT BLOOD.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO MARCH FORWARD DESPITE
THE FACTS THAT IT WILL INHE